the jurgen experience dude last night
okay last night on my security camera
there was a big black cat like a 60 70
pound [ __ ] something or another
well i don't know what it see the thing
about texas is this is a real issue
there's more tigers in captivity in
texas than
all of the wild of the world really
because of like richard's
[ __ ] just people just have a [ __ ]
fence i want a tiger and you could just
have a tiger
yeah because it's because of freedom
freedom america yeah like
zebras like my wife saw zebra once she
was driving on the road she saw this
[ __ ] [ __ ] zebra zebras just get
out right
like people have zebras and they just
get out sometimes well
whatever this thing was it's like can
you ride
are they short no they're horse-sized
they're it's a [ __ ] horse a wild
horse that cannot be tamed
no one has ever been able to tame a
zebra it's like trying to ride a wolf
like get the [ __ ] out of here i relate
maybe my spirit anyway i'm in the middle
of this
sorry outside of my [ __ ] house there
is a
a a big black cat yeah like a black
panther
i'm like like as big as my dog you know
my dog's like 80 pounds
this thing is like that size probably
like a little less than him
but it's a big [ __ ] black cat you see
its eyes
on the security camera walking down and
then my neighbor
who walks his [ __ ] dog at night his
dog is like on death's door right
it's like sweetheart of a dog but of
course and he's so he's got a head lamp
on
the dog no the neighbor this dog's like
trying to tell a story and you're
[ __ ] up my flow
punch lines excuse me this guy is
dragging his [ __ ] dog right
you know the dog walks slow and he's
kind of pulling him along on the leash
the cat runs towards them i'm thinking
i'm going to see a murder
were you a little excited be honest no
no because i had found out about it
after the fact i know he was okay
but it like it ran towards him and then
decided
last second to dart off into the woods
but like
it heard the footsteps turned the tail
and it just goes
running towards him like i thought he
was a [ __ ] deer or something
but it was creepy it was a big black cat
yeah i'm like more concerned how are
these people able to walk their dog so
close to my king's home i don't like
this
well they live in the neighborhood
they're walking around
but it's uh this [ __ ] cat is
wandering around
in like a residence that's crazy and
it's because it's from someone else's
house
i don't know what it is when i looked at
i just typed in uh
black panthers in texas in the wild and
what comes up is from not that long ago
it says the
wildlife officials say they don't exist
in texas and what you probably saw is a
black hog or otter and i'm like no no
that's
no nope not possible i thought you were
going to say it was like a black listen
i have a video yeah it's a black cat
there's no doubt about it no if fans are
a button i know what a hog looks like
they look totally different
a hog is a big bodied thing with with
little tiny ass legs i'm ready
okay and i'm still wearing my half
shirts i don't give a [ __ ] black
panthers do not exist in lone star state
that's not true i don't like lone star
it's not so sad
it's not it could have been private i
guess yeah that's my whole point yeah go
back up
listen that's what it looked like no
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's 100
that is a sexy animal if i was a girl
i'd want to get [ __ ] listen
my dad might be upset but if i was a
girl cat
see those things black panthers what
they are is um
it's uh the spots but the spots are all
over their whole body oh really
yeah so what that is is like a jaguar is
there skin
if you shaved it as their skin dark i
don't believe so
i don't know though might be um
show me uh like google
jag a black jaguar spots well there's
this thing
jaguar undies the mystery of the texas
black panther sighting solved
what is it the year before that i don't
know i mean i saw this too jaguar undies
those sound hot
they come in thongs one of my security
guys said he saw one in the woods
and he was i think he said he was
walking his dog too and he saw one in
the woods
a black panther he said it was just like
that and
he was the one who spotted this thing on
the camera
so they're [ __ ] listen i have a video
of it i believe
100 real so those [ __ ] from texas
wildlife need to shut the [ __ ] up
i got a video this thing is saying well
they probably are saying there's none
like just
in the habitat but it's because here's
here's why they don't know that
jaguars in particular have been spotted
in the wild in
arizona and they didn't think they used
to exist in arizona they thought they
were extirpated
bullet pull up jaguars in arizona it's
gonna be the cars
there's a lot of retired people i can't
help each other they're new cars
jaguars they still make them what's the
car okay when i make it
when i make my big bucks coming up here
what's my car
i think you need a convertible look at
you really i want to test the first see
these are jaguars
in uh in arizona pretty beautiful
gorgeous animal
you know i want to just wear that jacket
just get a fake one
of course i would never get a real one
don't murder the giant i would never
so someone killed that one the lower
left-hand corner that was the
they killed it in mexico and that was
like a famous jaguar
that was one of the two remaining
jaguars in the u.s it says
two remaining jaguars in the u.s but uh
i'm pretty sure they killed it
in go no no go back go back
um well that's really sad see the
left-hand corner
right about right below related images
see known jaguar
shown out right there yeah click on that
one because that article
um it explains how they know it roamed
southern arizona in 2016 but they killed
it in mexico
interesting to wear a matching dress
with the background does she have a
matching
jaguar dress no i'm just saying she was
wearing a blue oh but the background was
blue
you're such a girl i can't help it i
tried not to be
i do ah doesn't say
anyway i'm 90 sure they killed it in
mexico but
they live in mexico they live in
mexico-ish yeah
look at those slides um
they live in does it say killed by a
mountain lion hunter
it's a rumor that it was oh you heard
someone
trapped or killed one in mexico um
sonora mexico yeah that's what i heard
too um
but my point is that in south america
they're plentiful right they live in the
jungle like in the amazon they're very
dangerous like they jack people
all the time they're big it's a big
animal what do they do to them
they eat them oh they kill them they eat
people yeah
yeah do you know when people do
ayahuasca and they do it in the amazon
they have all these images of jaguars
and there's jaguars and snakes they're
like a big part of the the natural
imagery
yeah i did mine in chicago i was just
thinking deep dish pizzas and
they think they're taking on the spirit
of the jungle and
this is like you like all the things
you're afraid of in the jungle
and all the things that are in control
in the wild and the powerful forces of
the jungle
i don't know catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience